meet Bert camera from Florida Bird has
the best job in the world he designs and
flies miniature helicopters for
radio-controlled model companies when
this video of Bert doing his astonishing
stunts in Switzerland landed it scored
over 300,000 hits the skill involved in
this is truly unbelievable my favorite
move is when the helicopter comes
crashing down really quickly very close
to the ground and then he pushes ed
backwards and he saves it from his deep
dives
we tracked down Burton asked him to
explain how he does it for somebody to
learn to fly the way I do it would take
anywhere between three to ten years my
favorite moves are the Pierrot flip
which is basically a pure wedding while
the helicopters flipping happens all at
the same time another favorite maneuver
is de tick-tock and another favorite
maneuver is what we call the funnel
which is basically a tell down inverted
circle but could a full size helicopter
perform these intricate moves the
g-forces that would be experienced by a
real pilot would be way too strong to be
sustainable secondly we have the
power-to-weight ratio which means that
for a small helicopter the engine is
much more powerful and that allows him
to flip upside down and fly that way how
is bird pulling up his amazing maneuvers
so the first control the bird is using
is the main rotor blade firstly it
provides lift the next thing it does is
it can actually be tilted forwards and
backwards and by tilting it you can make
the helicopter go forwards or tilt in
the opposite direction you can push the
air out and it go backwards now the
other thing is is something called a
swash plate this allows the helicopter
to tilt in all directions which means he
can do that side way tilt and go nose-up
and nose-down you do all those crazy
motions if I won the machine to move
forward
I pushed forward here if I wanted to go
right I pushed right left and if I want
to go back I push back so flying
backwards is as simple as pushing back
on this stick right here and the machine
will fly backwards so the main rotor
gives the helicopter lift and moves it
backward and forward but what does the
tail rotor do
without the towel the helicopter body
would just spin around and so this rotor
blade at the back keeps it nice and
level you can also change the pitch on
the tail blades by moving the stick
right to left and by changing the pitch
on the tail blades you create lift
sideways allowing the helicopter to move
to one side or the other
[Music]
[Applause]